let's close this up where do we start
down this rabbit hole
i think this one over here is probably a
good one because um
it's got good engagement and um 5
million views this account has 7.3
million followers right now so
like just for fame guys i want you to
understand most of her audience is going
to be female and they are raving fans of
what she's doing which is basically
you know she's responding to
men's opinions
and then breaking them down uh you know
[ __ ] talking them and basically trying
to make fun of them or whatever you want
to call it
so let's throw
uh how do we throw this up full screen
there we go
let's pick this one over here because i
think this was a good starting point
give me some audio the amount of people
if women are stronger than men then why
the [ __ ] aren't we allowed to hit them
the amount of people that are pissed at
this video is [ __ ] hilarious
you think
do you really think that's hilarious
okay let's see if you still find it
hilarious after this one
this kind of argument really never makes
any [ __ ] sense first of all you're
not allowed to hit anybody
you guys know that right
yeah it's typically frowned upon for men
to hit women for obvious reasons but
legally speaking you're not allowed to
hit anybody it doesn't really matter the
gender and listen bro i don't know what
you [ __ ] look like but you look like
a popsicle stick come to life
so i don't think you should so i mean
she's already [ __ ] on the guy's
looks i don't i don't know if she has
mirrors in her house but
it's it's one ad hom attack after the
other with this one here
should be threatening to hit anybody to
be honest but as i was saying earlier
this weird obsession that misogynists
have with getting to hit women bro check
yourself into a [ __ ] hospital again
she's taken out of context i mean the
kid's just basically making an argument
because
women will often say that you know men
and women are equal and um you know we
should be treated the same and blah blah
blah what's good for the goose is good
for the gander and he's basically saying
well you know if men and women are equal
then why can't you hit women and i'm not
saying that's right or wrong but she's
taken into context that just allows her
to twist the words enough where she can
point and sputter back at the kid make
fun of him and you know suggest that
he's a misogynist i'm pretty sure she
used that word already twice just back
up a tiny bit here this weird obsession
that misogynists have with getting to
hit women bro check yourself into a
[ __ ] hospital
go get [ __ ] therapy when women say
listen don't treat me like garbage cool
and you're like okay nice come over here
so i can punch you in the [ __ ] face
you need help
you need help
not only that but this [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass you gave me exactly what i wanted
you gave me what i wanted you wanted
attention for being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's weird but okay also just a side
note are you being held hostage where
are you in a basement
why do you never blink in your videos
you look like the peanut butter baby but
no peanut butter
you look like tommy pickles if he grew
up and became a bigot
this is really hard to explain but you
look like this to me
bye
if women are stronger oh man so
that video had five million views and
the comments are endless on it like
it's it's it's
this is an example of what western
society now celebrates
um it celebrates
obnoxious
loud women like this
you can decide whether or not you find
her attractive it's entirely
subjective
but
front and center
big you know supportive female audience
basically saying that she's um you know
loving love in the playing field she's
giving it back to these misogynists
let's see what else we got in here let's
look for one with a big view count
uh 4.6 million so what is this
[Music]
all right so what does it say i'm
genuinely interested to see if she gets
into a relationship with a man so i'm
assuming this is her boyfriend
um
man bun dude um it's probably why she
makes fun of a lot of ball dudes the way
she does
oh this one's got nine million views all
right let's see what she's got to say
over here one of the ugliest [ __ ]
females
to be so uh
to be a spokesperson oh
damn
good one bryce
this video it was divine timing that i
saw it because i was in my notifications
and i was gonna pick somebody else and
then i saw you posted this [ __ ]
damn you really got me brother
the worst part of this video it's not
that you called me the ugliest [ __ ]
female you've ever seen or that your
idea of being funny is comparing me to
kermit the frog
is this thing on that joke sucked [ __ ]
that's not even the worst part the worst
part is your [ __ ] caption if she can
give heat sick and i that's your idea of
giving heat
god no wonder your [ __ ] feelings get
hurt so easily
nobody picked me because i'm the hottest
that's just a plus [ __ ] they picked me
because i'm the meanest and you're gonna
find that out the hard way unfortunately
so she admits that she has a following
because she's mean
right
society again western society the female
first primary social order is
celebrating a obnoxious loud
uh out of shape 26 year old that just
uses social media to bully and insult
guys that offer opinions about what they
like what they don't like it's funny
though because
if you like
if you're a dude and you publish stuff
like that the way that she's talking
about the opposite sex
that that tick tock that channel that
instagram you know whatever it might
happen to be on that platform would be
taken down very very rapidly
um but you know here we have 9.1 million
eyeballs on
this over here just let's just continue
to listen
cause i'll be damned if i let an
employee from zoomies talk [ __ ] on me
[ __ ] let's see what else we found in my
research
man
yeah that checks out [ __ ] so this obese
um 26 year olds laughing at guys that
are i mean they're they're thin but they
aren't obese that's for sure
that you are built exactly the way i
thought you were like a little lego
y'all look like you stick your fingers
up each other's butts to be funny do
y'all do that i bet you you do oh my god
i'll tell you bro like 5 4 i was 5'4
when i and then of course it it goes
from you know you look like a lego too
you're not tall enough
that's 10 so can't relate [ __ ] dog
you're adam's apple is out of control
get less adam's apple
that [ __ ] looks like a flamingo's leg
you also have the how do you how do you
exactly get less adam's apple and since
one was a masculine trait
this this
this is just uh well let's let's keep
going let's keep going
longest face why is your face so [ __ ]
long you know who you look like you look
like coraline's dad
that's gonna be you looking at the
notifications after this video [ __ ]
i also saw you're married does your girl
know that you spend your free time
looking at me
must not be that ugly
i'll tell you what though someone who's
not heavy enough to sit in the front
seat of a car i'm okay if they're not
attracted to me
i will move on i promise you that i'll
let you go though bryce cause i know
your shift at foot locker is gonna start
pretty soon
bye
so what did she do she insulted his
build his height
what he did for a living
pretty much everything
um
yeah it's it's
and this is what women follow like this
is what women celebrate
guys in my opinion you know i've said
this about things like the um
like there's podcasts out there like the
stupid ones like caller daddy and stuff
like that like if you like if you're
dealing with a chick that watches crap
like this red flag dude all day long
um
what else she got over here in her
repertoire of stuff 2.7 million 4.6 that
was the
boyfriend montage let's see what she has
to say about this
podcast
after
someone got rejected by a woman i wonder
if these girls started their podcast
because
someone was rejected by a man
come again
just for context this dude stitched my
last promo for my show and then took
three to five business days to spit out
this fire roast
that's an excellent question friend i'll
answer it free now although i will say
to start off i am impressed not by your
[ __ ] ass joke but by the fact that i
didn't know sweet potatoes could talk
i'll tell you the biggest difference
between my show and every other virus
called a man that has a podcast i get
paid so every man that has a podcast is
a virus so by definition gentlemen
you're listening to a
virus she calls it mr potato head or
sweet potato head was it but she but she
literally looks like the potato head um
doll that they had at when i was a kid
the little thing
eyeballs this is my full time
it was something that was offered to me
because i am funny i don't think that
you can relate to this because i'm
pretty sure you're the villain in every
james bond movie
you're busy too now on to the fire take
she barely just hates me because she's
rejected by them she's objected by one
and she's single
that's how you all sound to me
but to dispel any confusion i don't hate
terrible men because i was rejected by
them i hate terrible men because they're
terrible
the part y'all always seem to leave out
of that [ __ ] ass counter is that would
mean that i have to be attracted to you
and that is the most offensive thing you
could ever say to me
with all the disrespect the men who say
this [ __ ] look like a witch put a curse
on them a long time ago
y'all look like mole people i'm good
no ma'am and last to address the single
thing i'll be sure to tell my six four
man huh size 13 shoe do without what you
will bye
this is a dude over here look like a
witch put a curse on them a long time
ago
y'all look like mole people i'm good
no ma'am and last to address the single
thing i'll be sure to tell my six four
man huh
so
like this chick is lucky she's got a
dude
um
she's lucky she's got a dude say
that what's what's this over here dudes
who try to use really big words they're
like oh my god well let's actually have
a discourse let's have a look
no that's why i said doesn't matter how
many words you use yeah and did you just
use the did you just learn the word
discord are you just throwing around
literally they'll take that word satire
satire unpack yeah irony they're like
okay um
[Laughter]
holy for holy spot man
i'm just looking at this at this
flow here
here's another one with five 5.6 million
views
science teacher it says what's this yeah
do you think about it
first off i'm gonna say this i know this
video is gone now and i know you made a
follow-up
i also watched that unfortunately for me
and i also saw that one of my male
mutuals stitched you and in your
follow-up you were very respectful to
him let's see if you keep that same
energy [ __ ] this video was 20 years too
[ __ ] long
and it was a whole lot of words for i
have no [ __ ] game and i get zero
[ __ ]
i also saw it too that you said you're
engaged you have a fiancee does she go
to another school
if that's true if that's dead girl run
how you gonna get on here and humiliate
your [ __ ] girl like that dog come on
but i digress according to your
dissertation if women have a lot of
bodies they're [ __ ] and if men have a
lot of bodies they're not the reason for
this is that it's a lot harder to sleep
with someone than it is to allow someone
to sleep with you correct see how
[ __ ] easy it was to regurgitate that
misogynistic [ __ ] but at the very
end of your [ __ ] monologue you know
four scored seven years ago [ __ ] you
say that if any woman were to text any
man even if she's the biggest fan of
these [ __ ] in the world they would come
over immediately doesn't that make y'all
easy
you know what that sounds like to me
a [ __ ]
y'all are [ __ ] ran through if that's
the case women make it so hard they make
it so hard for us to [ __ ] them they make
it hard for you it's not hard for a lot
of it's not wrong about that when guys
don't have successful with women and
they complain about it it's most often
their fault
dudes but it's hard for you and every
other bitch-ass dude in that comment
section if it feels like an uphill
battle to get women to even converse
with you let alone go home with you
maybe it's because you're the worst
that's the thing about videos like this
men will jump through the biggest
[ __ ] hoop they will circulate [ __ ] to
justify why they're starved for [ __ ]
puss anything to not look in the mirror
and be like maybe i suck ass
there's there's entire channels
dedicated to pointing and sputtering at
the opposite sex and not taking
ownership for
their results in life as men your
inability to get [ __ ] is not women's
faults also you look like a middle
school she's not wrong about that either
your inability to get women i'm not
going to use her language is not women's
fault
school teacher and like you drive a cyan
but you know here comes all the insults
you look like at that other teacher you
look like you drive this kind of car
and to that i say no wonder you made a
video like this
i'm sending peace and love though not to
you but to your girl if she's real send
you all the good vibes man but this dude
can choke
bye
man but that's hey that's what that's
what's celebrated that's what society
celebrates they you know they susp
celebrate the
loud the vocals very masculine
um
you know opinionated disagreeable
it's uh
it's what it is man it's what it is
she's got some clips over here from
going to coachella
i'm sure you guys know about that place
yeah it is a it is a bit of a clown
world moth it is a bit of a clown world
out there but that's that's it man so um
i don't know like there's a lot of stuff
here on this uh
reddit um
female dating strategy and it's and it's
it's pretty um i mean this is just tip
the iceberg
this this drew it says here in the
description that's baba yaga to you ho
hashtag blm pronouns she her
anyway craziness ensues guys
so there's another red flag for you deal
with a chick that's uh
that's a big fan of
this
thing over here that stitches videos of
young men that are struggling it seems
and then tears them down even further
that's
that's what you're dealing with
jared said coachella equals socal std
fest
you won't have to endure anymore robert
you won't have to endure anymore let's
let's do this um and yeah like it could
be a bit of an act i'm assuming that
there's some acting to this but
how could you
put out this many videos
and get this much coverage and there's
also even media coverage too
um
yeah it's
it's insane and like women celebrate
this because they basically say oh she's
oh jesus is this her here
holy smokes
um
and they're and they're celebrating it
saying that she gets treated like a
queen by her boyfriend and that she's
putting men and sorry misogynistic men
in
in checkmate if you will
that's it
she'll make one on you after this
probably you know it's going to be the
standard oh look you're bald your beard
is whatever like i care the opinion of a
fat 26 year old doesn't matter hey guys
i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you